James, Erich, congratulations.
You're both in the final.
Now you're both one step
closer to redemption,
the title of "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and a check for $10,000.
When you came here,
you used our tools
and equipment to forge signature
blades in your signature style.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is--
a sword breaker.
Used by knights across
16th-century Europe,
the sword breaker
is a unique dagger
designed to render enemies
defenseless on the battlefield.
The weapon's sharp, comb-like
teeth could entrap and snap
an opponent's sword in
half, while its razor
sharp edge and tip were
employed to deliver
fatal slashes or stabs.
The sword breaker was so
versatile in its ability
to disarm and counterattack,
it became the standard sidearm
of its day.
Today, it's immortalized
in the PlayStation
game "Sword Art Online--
Hollow Fragment,"
where it's wielded
by the character Philia.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
ERICH: I'm back
in my home forge.
Last time I was on,
I was sent out first.
So to make it through to
the finals, I'm elated.
I'm assuming we're going to
try to break some swords,
and I'm all right with that.
I'm actually thinking
of going with a club
design for my teeth.
It's giving them
a lot more mass,
a lot more weight, and a
lot more meat to bite into
and to dig.
So hopefully that will
prove to be a good design.
Maybe someday it'll
end up in a museum.
I'm going to establish my
point and kind of narrow
that down, taking
the corners in.
I'm making a lot more
progress than I expected,
but the hard part's coming up.
The hard part's going to be the
meticulous parts of this build.
Time for day two.
First thing I'm
going to do is I'm
going to drill holes
and then finish
cutting all of those teeth
in before heat treat.
That looks pretty
wicked right there.
I was originally going to cut
these into the spade look,
but the triangular
look is really badass.
It's going to save me
a lot of file time.
Oh, so pretty.
I'm going to let this
forge warm up a little bit.
I've got to get my quench tank.
Then I'll be ready
for a hardening cycle.
I don't usually quench
blades this big,
so it's going to be difficult.
All right.
I'm heating up some scrap
material to heat the oil,
see if I can't get it
about 120 degrees in there.
You need to heat up the
oil because you don't want
to shock the steel
while hardening,
because it will
potentially crack.
Damn it.
What the [bleep] is going on?
I've got to--
I'm just fixing to waste about
two gallons of [bleep] oil.
[bleep]
The steel punches a hole in
the bottom of my PVC cap,
and that [bleep] sucks.
I don't know what the
[bleep] to do now.
This is going to set
me back a half day.
I need to find a quench
tank, or I'm done.
ERICH: I'm ready to get going.
I'm ready to get the
teeth on the blade today.
This is the most critical
part of the build, period.
This is the very first time
I've ever cut into a blade other
than a gut hook.
I'm going to hot chisel them
out just to see how they look,
making sure that that's
the right decision.
Of the designs I
have for my teeth,
they could go drastically wrong.
Each one of these teeth are a
potential spot for breaking,
so I have to be very meticulous
on where each placement goes.
I think it's going to be mean.
With the heat treat, I don't
know what to expect with it.
I truly don't.
If there's any stress
left in the metal,
it's going to come
out, and that is
usually in the shape of a warp.
That's got me a little
concerned, I got to say.
If anything is going to
make me throw up today,
it's going to be the heat treat.
That's really good.
They're nice and straight.
They look terrific.
I'm happy.
JAMES: I had to find
a different tank,
and finally I've
found a metal 5-gallon
can and quenched my blade.
It looks really good.
The details I'm
working on today is
I'm going to be
finishing the guard,
shape that up with some
files, make it nice
and round, shape my
handle, and do my test.
Ooh, that's nice.
Already have a
piece of purpleheart
wood from my handles.
And my drift for making
the hole for the guard,
it's going to now
become my pommel.
Everything looks great.
Now I have to get that primary
edge sharpened and then
do some cutting tests on it.
I got my daughters out
there and my tortoise, Gio.
They want to see what
this blade can do.
When I was out in
the first round,
my daughters were
both sad for me.
But having this second
opportunity to go back
and shown that if you
really put your mind to it,
you can achieve greatness,
it feels good to me.
That was pretty awesome.
It almost killed Gio.
To see what lethal
damage your blade can do,
I will deliver killing
blows of slashes and thrusts
on this ballistics dummy.
The sword breaker comes from
the style called main-gauche,
which means "left hand."
Therefore, I will see the
offensive capabilities of
your knife with my left hand.
James, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Well, James, as an
offensive weapon,
it slashes nicely and punctures
easily for a deep cut.
But at the same time, I
know that sword breakers
have to be held this way.
It wants to go this way.
Nonetheless, it cuts, it
stabs, and it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
Erich, your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Well, Erich, if I need
to use it offensively,
it's easy to index and
switch to that edge.
When I did thrust and slash
out, we got to test the edge,
and it lacerations.
Your blade will kill.
Thank you.
Now to test the sharpness
of the edge of your blade,
I'm going to cut the
rope first with the fish
and then the meat, our
"Forged in Fire" trifecta.
[laughter]
James, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Hell yeah.
All right, James,
wicked sharp.
Going from there, the sword
breaker in particular,
it's a left-handed weapon.
Now, that ring is to
protect your knuckles.
Oops.
Yes, sir.
Other than that,
this thing is a beast.
Thank you.
All right, Erich, let's do it.
OK.
[music playing]
[laughter]
All right, first
off, that's sharp.
It just went right through the
rope, right through the fish.
Didn't cut all the way.
That was me, not the knife.
You can see the
cuts on that beef.
JAMES: Yeah, sure.
Just clean, straight through.
Knuckle guard
above the knuckles.
Crenulations forward.
It can catch with
that, stop things.
That's great.
All in all, I think it's
a great-looking piece,
and it is definitely sharp.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen,
this is the strength test.
The sword breaker's
teeth were designed
to grab onto an opponent's
weapon and hold on fast.
Now, to test the strength and
durability of your blades,
we've hooked them into our
mechanical contraption here.
And what that piston
is going to do,
it's going to pull your blade
that way, bending that rapier,
putting a lot of
torque on your blade.
Let's see if the
teeth of your weapon
will hold on to that rapier.
James, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
3, 2, 1, pull.
[bleep] Damn it, man.
[laughter]
Oh.
OK.
You picked up an
ever-so-slight bend.
I mean, there was a lot
of pressure on that,
and you could actually
see that weapon bending.
You can see what it
did this rapier blade.
All in all, well done.
Thank you.
Erich, your turn.
Let's put it to the test.
In 3, 2, 1, pull.
[music playing]
All right, Erich, what
happened in our test
here is the shape of
your teeth, the way they
widen towards the outside--
ERICH: Yep.
--it allowed that rapier
to twist and pop out,
as opposed to when you see these
historically that they have
sort of a head on these teeth.
So once they go into that
section, it's harder for them
to escape.
The fact that this
opening here is so wide,
it just allows that to happen.
Sure.
Other than that,
I mean, it held up.
You bent the rapier
right until it popped.
Your blade stayed true,
even after all that flexing,
but those wide teeth seem
to be a bit of an issue.
My blade grabbed the rapier
and torqued it better than his,
but his sword didn't warp.
Mine did slightly.
So we're still neck and neck.
James, Erich, this was
your shot at redemption.
However, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one champion.
The "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
James.
[bleep].
Damn it.
Congratulations.
Well, thank you very much.
Erich, please
surrender your blade.
I agree with the
judge's decision.
I had some aggressive
choosing in the club pattern
for the blade.
But last episode I was
on, I definitely did not
show what I'm capable of doing.
This time, I was
able to put forward
a competition-worthy blade.
So that's redemption in itself.
James, congratulations.
You've redeemed yourself, and
you're the "Forged in Fire"
champion who also receives
that check for $10,000.
How do you feel?
Oh, man, it's
been a long road.
I'll tell you what, I
have redeemed myself.
All right, James,
please present
your weapon to the judges.
It's much more fun
to get to present
your weapon to the judges
than having to surrender it.
Two years ago, being
out in the first round,
then making it to the
championship round
and then now even
winning, and it's-- this
is truly redemption.
My daughters will be proud.
They can tell their
friends, hey, my dad's
a "Forged in Fire" champion.
[music playing]